nous vous l'apprenions en début de
journal les pilotes d'air france font
reparler d'eux ils lancent un mot
d'ordre de grève pour le 10 janvier
derrière leurs revendications il ya plus
qu'un problème
un gouffre le déficit d'air france un
déficit qui l'an dernier avaient atteint
plus de 350 millions de francs le
nouveau patron de la compagnie monsieur
giraudet avait décidé de reprendre les
choses en main et d'épongés par tous les
moyens ce déficit par tous les moyens
cela veut dire un certain nombre
d'économies draconiennes et par exemple
la suppression de quelques lignes de
prestige comme la semaine dernière celle
du pacifique
tout cela inquiète les syndicats qui se
demandent si l'on n'est pas de la veille
d'un conflit aussi dur que celui de 61
principal mécontentement des pilotes et
des mécaniciens navigants d'air france
la décision de la compagnie de fermer ou
de suspendre certaines lignes jugées
déficitaire et la mise à la casse d'une
quinzaine de ses boeing 707 à jugeait
trop gourmands en kérosène pour les
navigants ces appareils ne seront pas
remplacés les lignes abandonnées sont
loin d'être toutes déficitaires distille
et de toute façon une ligne perdu pour
air france sera récupérée par une
compagnie étrangère
elle ne pourra jamais être reprise la
compagnie n'est pas sur le chemin de
l'expansion selon le syndicat des
pilotes et des mécaniciens mais sur
celui de la récession la mise à la casse
de ses 700 7 à 2 c 15 avions long
courriers et la traduction la plus
significative actuellement de cette
politique de récession de la compagnie
et 15 longs courriers ça représente plus
du tiers le tiers environ des avions
long courrier de la compagnie ses avions
avait été on avait modifié leur planche
de bord l'année dernière pour le coût de
plus d'un million de nouveaux francs par
machine et on avait on les avait
préparés pour installer des centrales à
inertie et au coût de 0 4 million de
nouveaux francs par machine également
ces avions vont manquer considérablement
compagnie ça nous permettra pas d'une
part d'assurer les lignes sur lesquelles
elle a besoin de ses avions sur
certaines lignes
elle fera des réductions de fréquences
c'est le cas par exemple du paris
montréal chicago
d'autres lignes les fermera
partiellement le cas du new york
antilles en était par exemple ou
d'autres lignes ce sera la fermeture
pure et simple
c'est le cas du new york mexique et
c'est surtout le cas c'est le seul le
point le plus important de la fermeture
du leem ap ap tokyo le pour d'autres
lignes pour laquelle c'est l'avion
manqueront on aura recours encore plus
que par le passé à auzat traitement
c'est-à-dire que la compagnie air france
sera obligée de faire faire par d'autres
compagnies les lignes pour lesquels
n'aura pas le matériel adéquat pour le
faire est une conséquence très grave au
niveau des navigants c'est que quinze
machines que l'on enlève ça représente
le travail de d'environ 80 équipages à
raison de deux pilotes et des
mécaniciens par cockpit la suppression
de 15 boeing 707 à met en cause l'avenir
de 240 hommes à air france pour me
parler que du personnel technique leur
emploi n'est pas menacée oppose la
direction de la compagnie car nous
remplaceront les avions les wings 707 à
sont de vieux habits maison plus de 15
ans d'âge ils sont gros consommateur de
carburant
et comme toutes les autres compagnies du
monde meilleur nous avons à remplacer
ses avions par des appareils plus
performants et notamment les rebus entre
autres d'airbus et c'est ce que nous
faisons
quant aux suppressions de lignes que
vous évoquez elles sont d'abord fort
limitée elles portent principalement sur
la ligne dite du pacifique qui relie
tokyo à papeete et l'iman cette ligne
nous la supprimons parce qu'elle est en
déficit et qu'après quatre années
d'efforts d'efforts méritoires pour
essayer l'arrêt de la rendre rentable
nous arrivons à la constatation qu'elle
ne peut pas être rentable dans l'état
actuel des choses et par conséquent
jugeons raisonnable ne voulons pas faire
supporter aux contribuables français
le déficit d'une telle ligne ne
rechignera suspendant effectivement il
va y avoir des licenciements
non non nous allons évidemment avoir à
résorber le sureffectif
mais c'est déjà un problème que nous
connaissons nous connaissant wohlen
sureffectif dans le personnel navigant
et nous n'envisageons pas de
licenciements de ce fait le déficit
d'air france est élevé l'an dernier à
360 millions de francs responsable selon
la direction
le relèvement du prix du carburant et
les contraintes imposées à la compagnie
comme la desserte de deux aéroports à
paris et l'achat de matériel de pointe
coûteux comme le concorde 160 millions
de déficit en 1976 à rien pour ces
appareils
selon air france il faut assainir le
réseau et supprimer les vieux avions les
pilotes sentent le vent venir écrit
récession face à la concurrence
étrangère je dors mieux que cette grève
je ne la comprends pas et que je le
trouve choquant je ne la comprends pas
parce qu'elle s'appuie sur des raisons
qui sont par notamment 7 ce remplacement
d'avions de 707 à où cette suppression
de lignes pacifiques qui sont je crois
de fausses raisons puisque ces mesures
sont indispensables comme je viens de
dire je le trouve choquant parce qu'elle
intervient au moment où l'entreprise
fait un vigoureux effort de redressement
que nous essayons d'organiser leur sort
de donner à l'entreprise ressort
possible pour faire face à des
difficultés qui sont grandes et que
cette graine est tout à fait contre
courant et sans raison air france est
déficitaire comme british airways klm ou
alitalia lufthansa par contre ut
ailleurs un terreau swissair sont
rentables pourquoi c'est la question que
se pose la direction et les navigants
d'air france
chacun des deux camps rejetant la
responsabilité sur lot où est la réponse
qui peut prétendre pour l'instant la
connaître voilà avant de passer à la
météo il faut